Hunter Biden is not running for
president and Joe Biden is running for
president and yet and he is the
president and yet notwithstanding all of
the time effort and all of the moving
goalposts there's no evidence connecting
President Biden to any of his son's
business dealings and you can you know
you can sing all you want and make all
sorts of accusations but the fact of the
matter is that President Biden uh
there's been no evidence to show that
he's been involved in anything and so
Hunter will be treated by the Department
of Justice as he should be Devon Archer
Hunter Biden's business partner told you
inclosed door testimony that Hunter
would put his father on speaker phone uh
with while he was meeting with his
business associates uh shouldn't
President Biden have realized what
Hunter was doing here getting on the
phone talking speaker phone with his
business associates did he at the Le at
the very least show a major lapse in
judgment